uh hi thanks for choosing to
come to our talk my name is adam and
this is tomek we work at cider medical i
will be talking about
medical images and how we analyze them
how we use deep learning on them
to develop clinically useful
applications
and we'll split the talk in two parts
first tomic will tell you a bit about
what we do at cider
and he'll focus on 3d medical image
segmentation
and then i'll
talk more about
what we do with
segmentation and other computer vision
algorithms to develop
useful applications for clinicians to
treat patients and with that i'll give
the flow to atomic
okay thank you very much
let's first think about what is the kind
of product that we are
working with
um
okay
yeah so um siderev is a solution that
works during an
aortic repair in an endovascular way so
it's it's it's an endovascular operation
in which a surgeon do not directly
see the organ that he's operating on but
he relies on the 2d imaging so that the
thing you see on on the left x-ray
imaging yes and
furthermore
the soft tissues are indirectly visible
on on x-rays so to with outsider
surgeons needs to rely on injecting
contrast to the patient's body to
actually see the outline of the organ
they are operating on
and the main feature of of cider is that
it maps the 2d image acquired during the
operation
to the 3d anatomy that was acquired
pre-operatively and displays this uh
outline this
overlay of of the aorta on top of the
patient to help surgeons like navigate
during the procedure when they use their
tools and devices
inside inside the body
and the interesting kind of technical
thing here is that the main part runs in
the cloud on multiple gpu-enabled
machines
and it's displayed in the operating
theater okay but to get it we need the
segmentation uh to be to be available
yes so let's quickly revisit what what
we mean by that so medical image
segmentation is a kind of fully or
semi-automatic process that aims to
delineate the interested anatomical
structures yes it can be organs
tissues tumors it works on some medical
imaging modality like computed
tomography x-ray
microscopic slide and the output of it
in discrete setting at least is like a
segmentation map
uh let's say okay here is this organ or
all the other
um there has been a tremendous progress
in recent years in kind of deep learning
based models so unit which kind of is
depicted here is an encoder decoder
based model which is kind of a baseline
model for for image segmentation
uh
has already i mean made made a
lot of change and at any unit pronounced
no new net
it's actually a framework around it that
finds the best
model configuration and pre and post
processing
steps depending on your dataset
characteristics and it's kind of the
standard for
medical image segmentation nowadays it
was in 2020 it was used in 9 out of 10
top teams in 10 medical image challenges
that were performed there so
that's great is the problem solved even
what we have now well not really like
here i showed two quotes from some of
the papers that
still found that although in a kind of
overall quantitative way they show
quite well quite good results they still
seem to the mod these models seem to
generate like anatomically implausible
uh
results which is
not what we let's say want especially in
in this scenario to understand that we
need to revisit the metrics
um so two main
metrics that are used to to to measure
uh segmentation quality are dice source
and coefficient hauser and house of
distance we'll focus more on the first
one
today so it's an overlap
metric that that is um
yeah it's presented visually here it's
kind of twice the overlap twice the size
of the overlap divided by the sum of
both of these set sizes
and it's like
from zero to one zero means no overlap
one means a perfect overlap
um
but it kind of comes with its pitfalls
it's a pixel-based metric so it kind of
ignores the shape the topology of the of
the result yes so on the right you can
see a few artificial examples of some
predictions
that all gets the same score for for a
given reference shape and they are all
like totally different in terms of how
how do like a human would perceive them
yeah so
yeah this is like the
artificial example
how does this affect a real life so
here is um you can see a few
segmentations of the art i asorta is the
largest artery of of the human body it
starts from the heart and then splits
into into smaller arteries
and on the left you can see some
segmentation prediction from afro from
our model which gets like this value of
the dice score and on the right you can
see two manually perturbed versions of
it
and the first one has like a gap down
there
but it doesn't actually affect the ice
isco a lot yes because for it's kind of
volumetric
albeit it's like clinical consequences
if someone would try to understand this
segmentation would be would be really
i mean really large because it suggests
some you know blockage of the blood flow
or something at the same time here you
see a segmentation that has some
erroneous over segmentation
uh and it has like a
different die score now it's it's it
deviates more from the original one
although it would be clinically
acceptable yes this would be
th this is the kind of error that we
kind of can handle so
we know there exists a discrepancy
between
commonly used metrics and the kind of
human subjective uh quality uh estimates
so can we quantify this this is a
screenshot from one of the papers that
tries to do it so they
presented
clinicians
many segmentations and asked them to to
kind of say how good how good they are
on a scale of one to six and then they
tried to find the correlations between
those
and dozen of uh segmentation metrics
that are that are used in the world and
what they found is that the correlation
was like at most mild so they they found
like
uh that it was in the range of 0.4 to
0.5 the pearson's correlation
coefficient for the best metric so it's
kind of the
let's say the
best possible
example we found that a similar effect
in our internal experiments that like
the dice coefficient was
widely correlated with
human assigned score of how well does
this
how well is this segmented
okay so
let's think about what are the methods
that we can use to nail down the problem
so uh historically there was like before
the deep learning
era there was a lot of effort in the
segmentation algorithms and some of them
had like a built-in guarantees of of the
like preserving topology for example due
to how they worked now there is a trend
to combine those
and it it can be if you think about it
it can either be combined at the level
of the kind of network structure
architecture so how you
um how you build the model to uh
to behave or it can be we can use a kind
of a classical
cnn
but enforce it at the prior as this
prior at the lost level and one of the
examples is particularly
important in like the vessel
type of segmentations is a paper called
cl dies
centerline dice loss which i want to
cover a bit right now so
it works as a
as an additional loss component in which
we
include a center line
or a skeleton of a shape in the loss
function so center centerline or
skeleton is like a
thin minimized version of the shape that
largely preserves the extent and
topology of the original shape and what
the outers of this paper did is they
made and differentiable
skeletonization algorithm
and incorporated this directly in the uh
in the loss functions so that the
network can kind of be driven towards
preserving the um continuity and and
topology
um okay what are other challenges i
would just briefly cover the
technical challenges so to say so um
3d segmentation models like
especially like organ large organ
segmentations requires tons of memory
because if you want to pass like a
volume of you know 500 by 500 by 500
it's quite a lot if we want to train a
network on it there are a few solutions
how to overcome it one of them is to use
a course to find great models so
cascaded one when we first train a model
on a low resolution to identify like the
region of interest where where is the um
the actual
uh
object and then we train a fine-grained
model on the cropped on a kind of
cropped version which can be run on them
on a higher resolution but it has some
drawbacks yes it makes it complicated
it's it's multi-stage it's prone to
error propagation the other solution is
block sampling uh i show you like a 2d
version of it but in 3d it gets even
like
harder so we can sample blocks from the
whole volume yes because the whole won't
fit into memory we'll just get a part of
it but we face just like missing context
because kind of to solve the
segmentation problem looking at just a
small part of the image might not be
possible because you don't have the
context around but you can as well like
sample blocks that have no
or very low
amount of the foreground classes which
makes like the uh optimization process
harder because it's different
distribution than the original one
okay
to kind of summarize this part
i showed that medical segmentation is
kind of still a challenging
task it's an area of an active research
and
we've been able to kind of inspired by
the work done to use it
and apply it in a kind of working
product so how does this work then so
whenever
a new ct scan comes in to our system it
gets directly segmented by the deep
learning
model
and then is available for the clinician
in a planning tool to work on
and previously before this model was
introduced clinicians need to do it
manually using some region growing and
tools for for correcting the
segmentations and it took quite a lot of
time like
applying this this kind of algorithm
saves them 20 minutes for every case
they
they they work on and they can focus on
what they kind of want to do which is
they insert those virtual guide wires
and help them during the operation and
plan and decide on kind of what to do
okay and i will now
let adam tell you about like what's
what else can we do with the medical
image segmentation
okay thanks stomach uh hopefully you
learned something
new about medical image segmentation now
i'm going to focus on applications
beyond segmentation but using
segmentation as well as kind of the base
base layer
and i'll
split my part in in three subparts uh
first i'll tell you a bit more about the
disease that we're helping to treat
and what affects patient outcomes and
how we can affect them uh in indirectly
using our software
and then i'll try to convince you that
we have a
unique
database
which probably no clinicians have the
access to
kind of outside of
cider
and
i'll spend some time to describe
an experiment that we did
and i call it find similar patients
and uh and the basic premises how to
represent
very information rich data like ct scans
into something interpretable and
comparable
so endovascular aneurysm repair
is a
procedure
that helps patients with a an aneurysm
on the the main vessel in their body
the aorta
and an aneurysm is a as a bulge as a
weakening of the walls of the aorta and
one way of treating this disease is to
insert a stent graft which is this white
device
into the aorta to prevent the blood from
flowing
into the aneurysm
and therefore expanding it even more
because that can lead to rupture and
that's
very often fatal for the patient
but this
procedure
does not come without risks and
according to some studies there is
more than 15 chance of a patient coming
back
into the operating theater within the
first
within the three years after the initial
one and the initial procedure
and just to give you an example of what
can go wrong
an endo leak
is a complication where the the seal
between the device and the aortic walls
is not good enough and there's still
some blood flowing into the aneurysm and
it's still expanding
so a patient will be monitored after a
procedure
and
if
if the
doctor
sees that
disease is still there and still
expanding they'll
try to do another procedure
i tend to think there are two main
factors affecting the outcomes
and how successful a treatment is the
first is
the patient themselves
their anatomy comorbidities
general state of health
but we can't really control that i mean
we can
do our best with segmentation
uh with
annotating the data
um but the patient you know they come as
as they are
and then there are clinical decisions
and these are things like
what sort of device the clinician the
doctor will use during the operation
where exactly they will place it in in
the patient's body
or what other
adjunct procedures they will carry out
during the surgery
and these two factors affect outcomes
and we can definitely
have some control indirect on the on the
second part the clinical decisions
because as thomas showed you uh we
provide the software for planning these
procedures as well as
guidance during
the surgery
uh i want to
take a brief detour to explain a little
bit how knowledge and experience is
disseminated in the medical community
uh
using terms that we are familiar with as
programmers
so they have something like code review
which would be
meetings every
few days i guess
to review previous operations and
more experienced surgeons will share
their knowledge experience uh with
the less experienced ones
and that happens kind of within
operating teams within hospitals
uh there is literature of course the
the most
useful from our perspective is
when
researchers look at
large cohorts of of patients
retrospectively and try to identify
causal
relationships between
what happened during procedure or
planning and what the outcomes were
then there are conferences
and on some of these conferences it's
what's called the have live streaming of
of a live operation so there would be an
audience like you guys and they'll be
watching and a patient being operated
sometimes using
cydar
to help with with guidance and
navigation
and then there's of course the very well
known surgeon stuck overflow where
surgeons ask
for help when they have a complicated
patient anatomy
ah
of course there isn't such a thing
but i mention it
not just to make a joke they don't
that the problem is that surgeons
don't have this readily available source
of information about
patients that they don't
have
anatomies that they haven't encountered
before
or other
have out of after out of their own
experience distribution um
cases uh whereas we even if we
it's very unlikely that we've come
across a programming problem that
no one ever has
come across before but even if we do if
we ask a question on stackoverflow we
probably get an answer within a couple
of days maybe
but
also my point is that we at
cider have already helped
with about 3000 operations of this
specific disease
and that's much more than any
even the most experienced surgeon in the
world
uh have seen
so a surgeon will have a very deep
knowledge of the patient they'll follow
them along throughout other
treatments
but they may not have as much breath of
of knowledge and
just because you know they work at at
one aortic center so they see a specific
demographics of patients
or maybe they have
they have other constraints like they
can only use one type of device at their
center
so we're
part of our goal and mission is to think
hard how to
enable clinicians to tap into this
uh white
and deep pool of uh information that we
have outside our ct scans and
imagery from
from the
procedures
and the experiment that we did and i
want to describe that now the defined
similar patients experiment
is when
[Music]
we've got a
ct scan uploaded to our system
and then the goal
is to
do something with the scan and display
similar patients
similar anatomies
that we've seen in the past
and
that comes with
you know planning information so what
type of devices have been used for the
for those patients uh
uh
the the user querying our database for
for similar cases similar patients can
also review the imagery from from the
procedures
and they can get information about the
outcomes for these for these patients
but the crucial question is here
how to define similarity between
anatomies
are these anatomies similar
well
both of these patients have
aneurysms
pretty much all of our patients do
one is a bit lower down one is a bit
higher up
maybe the one on the right has a little
longer iliac arteries
below
but are they similar clinically are they
going to get a similar treatment
um how to how to define that
so we could go about it
naively
and
use our 3d binary segmentation model
the the unit
and
chop off the decoder part
and use the embeddings in the in the
middle
calculate the distances
distance of choice cosine distance
equilibrium distance
and
say that if the distance is lower the
patients are more similar
we can be
a bit
smarter about it and use existing
literature on similarity things like
triplet loss
and
siamese networks are used for that
we'd have to
get explicit labels about
pairs of scans which are similar or
dissimilar
and then we would train
a neural net
to
output and embedding a vector
that
again we can calculate distances
between
these vectors from different scans from
different patients
we've tried similar approaches
not specifically for similarity but for
for classification
uh but we think that the results are
kind of applicable also to similarity
the problem is that even though we have
a big data set for medical standards
3000 ct scans annotated
these ct scans contain a lot of
information these are millions of voxels
as in 3d pixels
and
they also contain a lot of information
that we don't that which are not that
relevant for
this specific uh specific disease there
are you know there are lungs in there
there are other organs in there
and we want to focus on the aorta
and the
papers that i've cited there and i
mentioned the the other approaches to
finding similarity
they use either million of
2d images like similar faces
or
thousands of cad models from which they
can
create projections and
generate the similar or dissimilar data
so we decided that we'll use
more of our in-house domain knowledge
to represent the anatomy in a way that's
comparable
and also a good side effect would be if
it if it's interpretable
because in the end we're going to show
it to clinicians
and it's a you know it's a feature if if
the data
the the black box that they're
a given
has some
uh it gives outputs which are
interpretable
uh atomic already mentioned the center
line or the skeleton
so we're going to use that
because it's a useful 1d
coordinate system that we can apply to
all of the segmentations that we get
from the ct scans
the second component of this
is our geometrical features so these are
you could call them more
traditional computer vision
algorithms
which calculate geometrical features on
the on the segmentation
along the center line
things like how bendy the aorta is or
what is the
cross-sectional area of of the
segmentation along the center line again
so with this we end up with a bunch of
1d features
but the remaining problem is that
we need to align them
because cp scans come they're not
standardized they some some of them end
at the neck level some would end at the
lung level and anything in between
uh so we trained the nodal another
segmentation model
and this time a semantic
segmentation one where each label
corresponds to
a you know a clinically defined
segment of the aorta
so now we can
align over all of our patients ct scans
say
at the with with the anchor at the top
of the abdominal segment of the aorta or
another segment of your choice
so the these three components the center
line the geometrical features and the
semantically labeled aorta
allow us to create
plots like the one in the center here
where we have the query
the the segmentation the anatomy on the
left
along with three nearest neighbors
and the the feature is
one of those geometrical the feature
plotted represented by the lines
is one of the geometrical features that
i mentioned
and that way we can
query our database for
patients which are for example the most
similar in the uh
in the visceral region where the
arteries that which are coming off to to
feed blood to other organs
are
or
you know similar in the upper upper
segment of the aorta
and we can give different weights to
different segments
and we can use different
features to
compute similarity
and the similarity computation itself is
could be just a like a cosine distance
between these lines
uh
and we we believe that's that's useful
because we're
showing clinicians
uh
again similar patients from the past
we're not really telling them
what to do
doctors don't really take it lightly if
you tell them what to do
um
but we're exposing them to too much more
information that would be available to
them otherwise
so then they can choose the right course
of treatment
and you know re-examine the
the patient with
the the extra information we're giving
to them
so in summary i hope that
i uh managed to convince you that we
have this unique database and there are
probably other databases scattered
around the world which are
useful and the problem is
for
companies with the access to those
databases to to give clinicians access
to them
in a way that's clinically useful
then my second point was that large
scale
facebook style similarity measures will
probably not work for such data sets
because the inputs are very information
rich and you probably will have to use
some domain knowledge to compress the
information
and
finally we
did an experiment which we think
the results were useful they were
evaluated internally by our experts
so if you have
domain experts at your
institution at your company
talk to them
what
figure out what they think is important
in in the data that you're analyzing
and
try to put it into
into your your solution
finally i just want to mention that we
are expanding our team
so feel free to reach out if you find
what we're doing interesting
with that i'll open the floor for
questions
hi everyone just raise your hand if you
have a question
hi uh thanks for your presentation um my
question is regarding the similarity
checks
my understanding is sometimes similarity
checks can fail
so um how do you get under those cases
where um
the results are not actually similar due
to some of the uh drawbacks of using a
deep learning system to attract to
extract um
similar features so how do you get to
undo those failure scenarios or sense
check that they're actually correct
so if i understood
is that working if if i understood
correctly the question is how do we
check for uh failures in our similarity
checks and you know how do we account
for them and how how do we prevent them
from happening and yes
well it's we can of course have some
selected test cases um and have unit
tests uh kind of on on the data
but
mostly i think it's also very important
to design
the the software your solution in a way
that
failure is not
catastrophic so we can still
show
uh a
patient's anatomy which is
according to the clinician will not
really be similar
but
it it won't you know it won't affect
their
uh their decision making because they
can
uh we we are giving them the freedom to
use use the information uh in in the way
that they uh they think is
most appropriate
so it's maybe about not being too
uh too explicit with the
conclusions of your algorithms it's it's
giving the the expert
uh room to decide
hello it's fantastic to see how cider
technology's come along so far over the
years
i work with large medical data sets and
i've and i'm wondering whether you have
any plans to
combine
the
anatomical similarity that comes from
the scans with
a measure of similarity
based on patient diagnosis or patient
medical history so similarity of
metadata versus similarity of anatomy
work that's a hard question i would say
uh so
i cannot say anything about the plans
precisely here what i just see is that
it would serve a bit of a different
purpose yes uh so um
like just for for helping to clinician
to plan the operation to decide on what
to do it
yeah comparing the anatomy seems like
the
first thing to do concentrating on
metadata
previous uh
patient history i see it as like a
for a different
for a different purpose
hi really interesting talk um i want to
ask about um getting the technology into
the nhs or another system like that so
it's talking to your cloud but in
particular getting data into and out of
those places are you covered by the same
sort of embargoes on patient specific or
pi based data um given that just sort of
only anatomical
and how do you get around that
so kate could you just read the second
one
um how do
other patient privacy concerns with the
type of data that you have if it's just
anatomical and how do you get around
those if so but how do you connect to
a hospital network for instance so i can
talk to your cloud and back because my
understanding of the nhs in particular
would be that that would not be allowed
but clearly it is
um
yeah we're just fortunate as machine
learning learning engineers to have
experts in the company who deal with
that part so we you know we're fully
regulated and uh we've got our
uh
indicates the uh caldecott guardian who
kind of deals with the data privacy uh
aspect of that so they're they'll they
deal directly with the nhs and at the
hospitals to to get the data
in a in an approved way
is there any more questions
great okay thanks very much guys um if
you have any more questions you can get
in touch with the guys
on the slack or twitter
cheers
[Applause]